schon bald sollen nur noch Wind und
Sonne unseren Strom liefern eine
Energie-
groß für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien das sie nicht zu überbieten
sind
doch was tun wir wenn die Sonne nicht
scheint und der Wind nicht weht wie kann
man diese Energie speichern wir haben da
draußen 32
wasserstoffflaschen und die sind jetzt
schon zu 62% mit Wasserstoff gefüllt den
grünen Strom festhalten mit
Energiespeichern mit welchen
Technologien kann das gelingen was
müssen Politik und Konzerne tun wenn wir
bis 2030 80 Prozent Erneuerbare Quote im
Strombereich haben wollen dann brauchen
wir auch mehr Speicherkraftwerke
[Musik]
das Haus von Familie schade aus Panketal
in Brandenburg
um möglichst vollständig auf grüne
Energie umzusteigen haben die Schaden
100.000 Euro ausgegeben
[Musik]
Vater Tobias und Mutter Stefanie wollten
grünen Strom mit Solarpaneelen auf dem
Dach gewinnen doch die Sonnenenergie nur
tagsüber und im Sommer zu nutzen war
ihnen zu wenig
Tobias schade recherchierte wie könnte
er den Sonnenstrom für die dunkelzeiten
im Winter speichern
[Musik]
Wasserstoff war schon immer so eine Idee
das muss doch irgendwie funktionieren es
klingt so einfach aus
Wasserstoff machen aus Wasserstoff
wieder Wasser und Energie das muss doch
irgendwie gehen so schwer kann es ja
nicht sein Tobias schade stieß auf eine
Firma die Wasserstoffspeicher für zu
Hause anbietet es ist Januar 2022
Familie schade hat die Anlage gerade
erst einbauen lassen mit Hilfe des
Solarstroms vom Dach erzeugt sie
Wasserstoff
dieser Wasserstoff könnte die Familie
unabhängig vom öffentlichen Stromnetz
machen
denn mit Hilfe einer Brennstoffzelle
kann aus dem Wasserstoff wieder Strom
erzeugt werden
ich bin jetzt nicht so prepper oder so
und denke jetzt geht morgen die Welt
unter aber zu wissen dass man falls der
Strom ausfällt sozusagen eine kleine
Insel hat es ist und fühlt sich
irgendwie sicherer an eigentliche ankam
war
Energie selber zu produzieren so sauber
wie möglich und auch speichern zu können
100.000 Euro sind ein hoher Preis für
Strom der aus dem öffentlichen Stromnetz
deutlich günstiger zu haben ist doch der
Hausarzt und die Lehrerin Handeln aus
Überzeugung
wir hatten das Geld tatsächlich also ich
hatte keinen Kredit dafür aufgenommen
oder so und
wollten es investieren sinnvolle Sache
also man hätte schon einen schicken
Tesla auch kaufen können aber den wollte
war halt nicht wir wollten
Wasserstoff produzieren
großer Wermutstropfen bei der Gewinnung
und rückverstromung des Wasserstoffs
gehen rund 60% des Sonnenstroms verloren
ob die Schades mit dem gespeicherten
Strom über den nächsten Winter kommen
[Musik]
die Frage nach Strom speichern stellt
sich nicht nur für die Schades sondern
auch für Deutschland insgesamt je höher
der Anteil von Wind und Sonnenstrom im
Stromnetz liegt desto stärker schwankt
die Versorgung bei reichlich Wind und
Sonne ernten wir schon heute mehr grünen
Strom als wir brauchen und bald soll
noch viel mehr grüner Strom kommen in
seinem osterpaket steckt
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck im April
2022 neue ehrgeizige Zielmarken
die Pläne der Bundesregierung sind so
groß für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien in der Geschwindigkeit dass sie
nicht zu überbieten sind Deutschland
will bis 2030 80% seiner Energie
erneuerbar produzieren wenn das klappen
soll müssen immer mehr fossile
Kraftwerke ausgeschaltet bleiben doch
woher soll der Strom dann kommen bei
Nacht oder wenn der Wind nicht weht
Energiespeicher müssen her mahnen
Experten wie energieökonomen Claudia
Kempfert vom Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung die Energiewende
muss man vom Ende her denken das heißt
man muss immer sich schon in Zeiten
hinein bewegen wo wir über 80 Prozent
erneuerbare Energien im System haben das
wird ja passieren in der nächsten zehn
Jahren und zur Energiewende dazu gehören
die Speicher und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass man sie von Anfang an mitdenkt das
heißt sie muss man deutlich mehr und
weiter denken als bisher
Speicher sollen überschüssigen Strom aus
Wind und Sonne aufnehmen und ihn nachts
und bei Flaute wieder abgeben in
gigantischen Mengen wie soll das
funktionieren
aufgestautes Wasser ist bisher die
einzige Technologie die Energie aus dem
Stromnetz in größeren Mengen speichert
so wie hier an der Silvretta Staumauer
in Österreich
die Turbinen das dazugehörigen
Kraftwerks liegen tief im Fels darunter
2018 ging es ans Netz und soll helfen
die Schwankungen durch Wind und
Sonnenstrom im Stromnetz auszugleichen
wird Energie gebraucht jagt Wasser aus
dem Stausee durch die Turbinen und
erzeugt Strom doch wenn mittags oder bei
starkem Wind zu viel sonnen oder
Windstrom ins Netz kommt kann die Anlage
diesen Strom durch hochpumpen auch
speichern eigentlich ganz einfach
ja wir hängen am deutschen elektrischen
Netz und da hängst du davon ab wie viel
Sonne gerade in Deutschland steht wie
viel Solarenergie und wie viel Wind das
geht bei übertappazitäten im Netz werden
bei uns die Maschinen auf pumpbetriebe
umgestellt und wir pumpen das Wasser vom
unteren See in den Oberen See so
speichert das Kraftwerk erneuerbare
Energie der Sonne in Form von gestautem
Wasser
rechnerisch könnte es damit mehrere
tausend Haushalte für ein Jahr versorgen
Speicher sehen fangen schon heute einen
Teil der Schwankungen aus Windkraft und
Sonnenenergie im Stromnetz ab in
Deutschland gibt es aktuell mehr als 20
Pumpspeicherkraftwerke und mit der Wende
zu grünem Strom dürfte der Bedarf
deutlich wachsen
trotzdem ist hierzulande seit 2003 kein
neues Pumpspeicherkraftwerk mehr ins
Netz gegangen
dabei gab es an verschiedenen Orten
Pläne für solche Energiespeicher
seit 2010 engagiert sich Rudolf Schöller
von den Stadtwerken Trier mit Herzblut
für ein Pumpspeicherkraftwerk das
Projekt nannte er Rio nach der ersten
Klimakonferenz im Jahr 1992
die Idee für dieses schrafter cRIO zu
bauen war die erneuerbare Energie an
diesem Standort auszuregeln um
letztendlich die erneuerbaren Energien
aufzunehmen wenn sie im Überschuss da
sind um sie eine halbe Stunde später
wieder abzugeben wenn die Sonne uns mal
im Stich lässt oder der Wind nicht weht
um ein permanentenausgleich der
erneuerbaren Energien zu haben hier auf
dem hummelsberg oberhalb der Mosel
nördlich der Stadt hätte das obere
Staubecken für die speicheranlage
entstehen sollen
der Standort ist deswegen ideal weil er
ein Gefälle hat zu unserem Unterbecken
zu von über 200 Meter und da wir eine
Infrastruktur haben die einfach ideal
ist für den Bau eines
Pumpspeicherkraftwerkes wir haben über
uns eine bestehende Hochspannungsleitung
an die man das Kraftwerk anschließen
kann
Schöller und seine Kollegen legten sich
ins Zeug eine Machbarkeitsstudie brachte
ein positives Ergebnis auch für das
geplante untere Staubecken und das war
natürlich ein gigantischer Schritt das
war ein Ruck in der Mannschaft das war
ein Ruck in der Presse und jeder hat
gemeint jetzt geht's auch weiter und
dieses Projekt geht in die
Realisierungsphase doch dann folgte der
Rückschlag kein Energieversorger in
Deutschland wollte mit einsteigen mit
den Anlagen lasse sich kein Geld
verdienen hieß es überall doch allein
konnten die Trierer Stadtwerke das
Großprojekt nicht stemmen und legten es
2017 auf Eis
ja wie fühlt man sich wenn man
eigentlich sechs Jahre oder sieben Jahre
aktiv an diesem Projekt alles gegeben
hat was irgendwie geht ja das ist
natürlich eine Rahmen schwarzer Tag man
kann nicht weitermachen obwohl man genau
weiß es müsste weitergehen um die
Erneuerbaren nutzbar zu machen
nicht nur das geplante Pumpspeicherwerk
bei Trier blieb auf der Strecke
insgesamt wurden in Deutschland mehr als
10 ähnliche Pumpspeicheranlagen in der
Planungsphase gestoppt für Rudolf
Scheller ein Skandal in der ganzen
Bundesrepublik gibt es kein Kraftwerk
was im Bau sich befindet wo man sagen
könnte dieses Kraftwerk ist im Bau und
soll in einem Jahr in Betrieb gehen um
dann speichern und Regel Energie für
erneuerbare Energie zu liefern es gibt
viele Pläne aber kein reales
Kraftwerksprojekt der Grund Gebühren wie
Netzentgelte und EEG-Umlage verteuerten
gespeicherten Strom
obendrein hatten Energieversorger mit
langfristig niedrigen Strompreisen
kalkuliert
unter diesen Bedingungen wären Speicher
ein Verlustgeschäft
energieökonomin Claudia kämpfert vom
Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung sieht hier Fehler
der Politik damals war die Einschätzung
die Anlagen sind nicht wirtschaftlich
das ist auch politisch gesteuert gewesen
weil man eben sehr hohe Netzentgelte bei
Einspeisungen Ausweisungen hatte das
macht die Anlagen dann tatsächlich nicht
wirtschaftlich aber heute mit dem hohen
Strompreis würden sie sich alle rechnen
und es ist auch im höchsten Maße
bedauerlich dass wir sie nicht haben
weil wir brauchen sie dringend für die
Energiewende
offenbar haben Politik und Konzerne den
schnellen Zuwachs von schwankendem Wind
und Sonnenstrom unterschätzt und damit
den Bedarf an speichern können wir das
aufholen
während der Bau neuer Pumpspeicher nicht
vorankommt setzen Energieversorger
zunehmend auf andere Technologien
sind Batterien die Lösung diese
Versuchsanlage in der Nähe von Dijon in
Frankreich steckt voller Lithium-Ionen
Zellen sie speichern 24 Megawattstunden
genug um rund 500 Haushalte gut eine
Woche lang zu versorgen könnten solche
großbatterien die Schwankungen von Wind
und Sonnenstrom ausgleichen
weltweit arbeiten forschende an immer
besseren Batterien an der TU Berlin
untersucht Julia Kowall wie und warum
die Zellen Alter und ihre Kraft
verlieren sie ist überzeugt Batterien
können nur ein Teil der Lösung sein
wir brauchen Speicher unbedingt weil wir
ja einfach keine dauerhafte
Stromversorgung haben durch Solar und
durch Wind Energie Lithium-Batterien
können eingesetzt werden um kleinere
Schwankungen auszugleichen also
insbesondere so innerhalb eines Tages
oder auch innerhalb von einigen Tagen
oder Wochen aber wenn man genug Energie
für den Winter in Lithium-Batterien
speichern möchte dann müsste man einfach
wahnsinnig große Batteriespeicher bauen
und das macht einfach irgendwann keinen
Sinn mehr
verglichen mit Brennstoffen wie Gas oder
Benzin haben Batterien immer noch eine
geringere Energiedichte speichern also
weniger Energie
was können Batterien in Zukunft leisten
und könnten neue superbatterien schon
bald alle Speicherprobleme lösen also
die Batterie der Zukunft die sollte
natürlich eine 10 Mal so große
Energiedichte haben eine wahnsinnig
lange Lebensdauer recyclebar und sicher
aber das geht einfach alles nicht
gleichzeitig
Batterien werden also auf absehbare Zeit
noch Nachteile haben glaubt die
Forscherin
der Abbau des Lithiums und anderer
Bestandteile belasten die Umwelt sowie
hier in der Atacama Wüste in Chile
und um große Energiemengen vom Sommer in
den Winter zu bringen dürften sie auch
weiterhin zu schwach bleiben wenn man
über Speicherung nachdenkt muss man sich
einfach klar machen dass man einfach
enorme Energiemengen braucht
insbesondere wenn man von den vom Sommer
in den Winter speichern möchte und da
reichen ein paar Pumpspeicherkraftwerke
nicht aus da reichen ein paar
Batteriespeicher nicht aus ich denke
dass wir für diese saisonale Speicherung
vor allen Dingen auch viel Wasserstoff
brauchen werden
grüner Wasserstoff er ist seit Jahren in
aller Munde liegt hier die Lösung
Sonnenstrom für den Winter zu speichern
in Dresden entwickelt ein Start-up
Anlagen die Wasserstoff gewinnen können
Chefingenieur Christian von olshausen
und sein Team arbeiten an Technologien
das begehrte Gas besonders effektiv zu
gewinnen das Modul hier hinter uns sieht
dann ist das eins was ungefähr 0,25
Megawatt aufnehmen kann in Zukunft wird
ein solches Modul bei der nächsten
Generation zwei Megabad aufnehmen die
multiplizieren wir dann nebeneinander um
dann in die Größenordnung zu kommen die
wir für die Energiewende brauchen
noch allerdings liefert die Firma nur
wenige Anlagen aus um große Mengen von
Wasserstoff zu erzeugen müsste man auf
Massenproduktion umstellen
das Herz der Anlagen der sogenannte
Elektrolyseur kann mit grünem Strom aus
Wasserstoff gewinnen im Winter könnte
man aus dem Wasserstoff wieder Strom
erzeugen klingt einfach
doch Wasserstoffgas braucht sehr viel
Platz
in einem solchen Haus hohen Tank passen
nur rund 200 Kilo gerade genug für den
jährlichen Stromverbrauch einer Familie
Wasserstoffe ein ganzes Land wie
Deutschland zu speichern ist somit ein
Problem
Tanks werden nie eine große Dauer haben
das kann immer mal ein paar Minuten oder
auch noch wenige Stunden sein aber große
Tanks sind zumindest meiner Einschätzung
nach nicht die großen Energiespeicher
der Zukunft
Wasserstoff in großem Stil zu lagern
dürfte ohne weiteres nicht klappen das
sehen auch die Entwickler der
Wasserstofftechnik
[Musik]
Familie schade in Brandenburg will
zumindest kleine Mengen
wasserstoffspeichern ihre
wasserstoffanlage arbeitet jetzt im
Sommer auf Hochtouren auch die Kühlung
der Eiswürfel läuft mit Solarstrom vom
Dach
wir produzieren seit März setzt
Wasserstoff da lief die Anlage richtig
an und sehen ja wie jeden Tag sich der
Speicher füllt ich gehe davon aus dass
wir uns größtenteils auch über den
Winter versorgen können und bin jetzt
schon total happy dass wir das gemacht
haben
zugesehen in einer App sehen die schade
wie viel Wasserstoff sie jeden Tag
produzieren und wann sie wie viel Strom
verbrauchen
ich bin bisher mit der Entscheidung
zufrieden tatsächlich müssen wir jetzt
ein oder anderthalb Jahre mal mit der
Anlage Leben um zu schauen welche Werte
tatsächlich dann rauskommen ich bin da
nicht ganz so optimistisch wie Tobi ich
glaube wir werden es nicht vollständig
autark schaffen denn schon jetzt im Juli
sind die 32 schweren Stahlflaschen
weitgehend gefüllt insgesamt fassen sie
gerade einmal 37 Kilo Wasserstoff genug
für 600 Kilowattstunden Strom um damit
durch die dunkle Jahreszeit zu kommen
müsste die Familie äußerst sparsam leben
erst im Winter wird sich zeigen ob der
Wasserstoff gereicht hat
alle Speichertechnologien haben heute
noch Nachteile
Pumpspeicher und Batterien können Strom
zwar für wenige Stunden vom Tag in die
Nacht speichern doch um Energie vom
Sommer in den Winter zu bringen reicht
die Kapazität nicht das ginge mit
Wasserstoff der sich jedoch aufgrund des
enormen Volumens in Tanks kaum speichern
lässt
doch längst keinen forschende Methoden
den Wasserstoff in leichter
beherrschbare Energieträger umzuwandeln
so wie hier in Karlsruhe in einem
chemischen Reaktor erzeugen Siegfried
bior und sein Team aus Wasserstoff mit
Haaren den Hauptbestandteil von Erdgas
die Erdgasspeicher die wir momentan
haben und die eben so ein Vierteljahr
oder sowas an Speicherkapazität
Deutschlands abdecken die können Sie
natürlich füllen und dann haben Sie auch
über Monate
Energie gespeichert in Form von
chemischen Energieträgern
dieses aus Wasserstoff gewonnene
klimaneutrale Erdgas könnte dann
Gaskraftwerke befeuern oder in der
Industrie verwendet werden
die Forschenden haben die Anlage
entwickelt und auf Herz und Nieren
getestet um in der Energielandschaft
eine Rolle zu spielen bräuchte man
allerdings deutlich größere Anlagen
was wird hier in den letzten Tagen und
auch in den letzten Jahren gemacht haben
sind die Daten zu sammeln die wir eben
dafür brauchen um eine größere Anlage
berechnen zu können also diese Anlage
hoch zu skalieren auf den großen Maßstab
die Technologie hat ihren Preis selbst
jetzt nach dem Ende der russischen
Gaslieferungen wäre solches grünes
Methan mehrfach teurer als normales
Erdgas
wie viel ist es uns wert elektrische
Energie zu speichern mit dieser
Technologie ganz klar wird es dadurch
teurer aber ich habe natürlich die
Möglichkeit Langzeit große Mengen an
Energie zu speichern was mit anderen
Speichertechnologien nicht geht die
Technologie grünen Wasserstoff in
künstliches Erdgas umzuwandeln ist da
doch weder Politik noch Unternehmen
haben bisher begonnen das Verfahren
ernsthaft in die Praxis zu bringen es
ist sehr wichtig dass wir Wasserstoff im
Methan und auch synthetisches Erdgas
umwandeln weil wir es nutzen werden
müssen in der Zukunft in z.B
Gaskraftwerken die wir dann brauchen
wenn eben die Sonne nicht scheint und
der Wind nicht weht das muss man heute
anschieben inklusive der deutlich
schnellere Ausbau aller Öko-Energien
aller erneuerbaren Energien
weltweit suchen forschende nach
alternativen Technologien um grüne
Energie zu speichern
um die Kraft der Sonne zumindest für die
Nachtstunden festzuhalten setzt man in
Chile auf Wärmespeichern mitten in der
Atacama Wüste ging im Juni 2021 sero
Dominator eines der modernsten
solarzttermine Kraftwerke der Welt
10.600 Spiegel bündeln das Sonnenlicht
auf einen wärmerezeptor an der Spitze
des Turmes dort erhitzt die Kraft der
Sonne ein flüssiges Salz
ja natürliche Zustand dieses Salzes aus
dem Norden Chiles ist fest das hier ist
es aber bei Temperaturen über 265 Grad
wird es flüssig der große Vorteil ist
dass dieses Salz sehr viel Energie
aufnehmen kann und die bleibt erhalten
weil die Tanks sehr gut isoliert sind
im Inneren des Tanks zirkuliert das
geschmolzene Salz bei einer Hitze von
bis zu 600 Grad es speichert die Energie
der Sonne als Wärme
daraus gewinnt das Kraftwerk nachts den
Dampf für die Turbinen und kann so auch
ohne Sonne bis zu 17 Stunden lang Strom
liefern
für solche Kraftwerke reicht in
Deutschland die Sonneneinstrahlung nicht
doch Wärmespeicher gibt es bei uns
an diesem 50 Meter hohen Speicher für
heißes Wasser in Heidelberg mit
äußerlich noch gebaut doch die Anlage
läuft schon die verantwortlichen Manager
der Stadtwerke sind überzeugt vom nutzen
das Projekt
also wir brauchen grundsätzlich mehr
Speicher in alle Richtungen also wir
brauchen mehr Speicher im Stromsystem
und wir brauchen auch eine Steuersystem
warmes Wasser ist ein gutes
Speichermedium ist auch ein günstiges
Speichermedium und vor allen Dingen kann
man sehr viel Energie in Wasserspeichern
und wir haben ein großes
fernwärmelsystem in Heidelberg und da
war das die Überlegung ein großen
Speicher zu bauen die die auch jetzt zu
dem Projekt geführt hat
die Technik für die riesige Isolierkanne
ist so einfach wie effektiv
das hier ist die Isolierung und die
sorgt dafür dass die Wärme sehr lange
mehrere Wochen und Speicher gehalten
werden kann ohne abzukühlen damit
Deutschland klimaneutral wird muss in
Zukunft nicht nur der Strom grün werden
auch fürs Heizen das den größten Teil
des Energiebedarfs ausmacht dürfen wir
kein Gas und Öl mehr verfeuern
diese Heidelberger Neubausiedlung wird
komplett mit Fernwärme versorgt
noch kommt die Wärme aus einem
nahegelegenen Kohlekraftwerk und dem
Holzheizkraftwerk der Stadtwerke Abwärme
die bei der Stromerzeugung entsteht
landet so erstmal im Speicher das spart
CO2 und Geld besonders bei dauerhaft
hohen Energiepreisen und der Speicher
kann noch mehr über einen Umweg nimmt er
auch den Strom der Erneuerbaren auf dank
eines elektrischen Heizkessels
der elektrokessel ermöglicht es uns das
Stromnetz zu verbinden mit dem
Wärmespeicher wir können über diesen
Kessel Strom aus erneuerbaren Energien
gerade wenn sehr viel davon gibt wenn
der Wind weht und die Sonne scheint
können wir umwandeln in Wärme in
Heizwasser und wenn es benötigt wird
können wir es dann aus dem Wärmespeicher
in der Stadtnetz Pumpen noch haben sie
nur einen kleinen Heizkessel der nur
wenig grüne Energie in den Wärmespeicher
bringt ein größerer Kessel ist geplant
wir haben den bisher noch nicht gebaut
weil die ganzen regulatorischen
Rahmenbedingungen und die gesetzlichen
Rahmenbedingungen heute noch nicht so
sind auch was die Förderung angeht dass
die Anlage für uns wirtschaftlich
Betreiber wäre denn um Abwärme aus Kohle
oder Heizkraftwerken zu speichern
erhielt der Wärmespeicher Fördergelder
für die Speicherung erneuerbarer
Energien jedoch nicht
wie bei anderen Speichertechnologien
auch hinkt die Politik den
Erfordernissen der Energiewende
hinterher dieses Projekt mit dem
Wärmespeicher hat am Ende des Tages 10
Jahre gedauert wenn man dann das Ziel
hat 2030 möglicherweise schon erneuerbar
zu sein da muss man alles spätestens
2025 angefangen haben alles wenn wir da
sehr sehr lange drüber reden und
diskutieren dann fehlt uns die Zeit am
Ende die wenig haben
nicht nur Stadtwerke und regionale
Energieversorger sorgen sich das
Deutschland zu wenig Speicher aufbaut
[Musik]
en ist und leitet den Verband
energiespeicherunternehmen mit seinen
Förderungen nach mehr speichern fand er
bisher wenig gehört
letztlich muss man konstatieren dass die
Politik und auch die Regierungen der
vergangenen Jahre und der vergangenen 10
15 20 Jahre
die Notwendigkeit von Speichern
letztlich verschlafen hat da muss jetzt
endlich nachgebessert werden weil sonst
die Energiewende am Ende nicht
funktionieren wird
mehr Speicher das ist sein Job doch
inzwischen warnen auch ExpertInnen wie
Claudia kämpfert ohne Speicher könnte es
bald eng werden wir brauchen in der
Zukunft eine breite Palette an
Speichertechnologien wir werden in einem
System sein mit mehr erneuerbaren
Energien das viele Schwankungen aufweist
das heißt es gibt Zeiten wo wir ganz
viel Energie haben das müssen diese
Energie müssen wir speichern für die
Zeiten wo wir dann weniger Energie haben
doch beim grün geführten
Wirtschaftsministerium in Berlin so
scheint es fehlt noch immer eine
umfassende speicherstrategie
Wasserstoffspeicher sollen zwar
gefördert werden darüber hinaus jedoch
setzt man offenbar auf die Initiativen
anderer
ich sehe die Dringlichkeit auch aber ich
erkenne das ganz viele Akteure auf dem
Weg sind das auf diesen
Herausforderungen sich zu stellen das
sind alles kleine Bausteine und der
Ausbau der
Wasserstofftechnologie das ist der
größere Baustein der uns stärker fordert
aber im Grundsatz sage ich mal ist
technisch die gesamte Herausforderung
erkannt es geht jetzt um Umsetzung es
geht um gute Förderung es geht um gute
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Hund Land und
Kommunen
nach viel Initiative klingt das nicht
außer bei der Abschaffung der EEG-Umlage
und den Bekenntnis zum wasserstoff hat
auch das grüne Ministerium beim Thema
Speicher bisher kaum Impulse gesetzt
in Trier bei den Stadtwerken haben
Rudolf Schöller und seine Kollegen nach
über 5 Jahren die Pläne für den nicht
gebauten Pumpspeicher noch einmal aus
der Versenkung geholt
denn mit gespeichertem Strom könnten die
Stadtwerke ihre Kunden vor extremen
Preissprüngen an den Strombörsen
schützen
und hier tauchen im tagesmittelpreise
auf von über 1000 €. da steht jetzt
unser Geschäftsmodellen neue Art und
nicht am Fliegenfänger zu hängen kaufen
zu müssen um jeden Preis
die neuen Ziele der Politik für die
Energiewende machen für Rudolf Schöller
die Frage nach Stromspeichern noch
dringlicher
wenn wir bis 2030 80 Prozent Erneuerbare
Quote im Strombereich haben wollen dann
brauchen wir auch mehr
Speicherkraftwerke und die müssen wir
heute bauen und nicht in zehn Jahren
damit sie 20 30 fertig sind
während in Trier neue Hoffnung keimt ist
in Brandenburg der Winter eingekehrt
seit etwas über einem Jahr lebt Familie
schade jetzt mit ihrem eigenen
Wasserstoffspeicher der Strom den sie
jetzt in der dunklen Jahreszeit
verbrauchen kommt aus der
Brennstoffzelle im Keller
[Musik]
naja guck mal und jetzt müssen wir mal
schauen wie viel Wasserstoff haben wir
denn eigentlich noch warte mal im
Prinzip kannst du jetzt sehen super 20
Prozent sind noch da wir haben Mitte
Januar naja also bis Ende Januar auf
jeden Fall
wie ist das Fazit nach einem Jahr mit
der Anlage
der Wasserstoffspeicher
bringt ein gutes Gefühl eigene
gespeicherte und hergestellte
Sonnenenergie im Winter zu verbrauchen
man kommt leider noch nicht ganz durchs
ganze Jahr für den nächsten Winter haben
die schade sich deshalb einen
zusätzlichen Wasserstofftank bestellt
noch ist das System deutlich teurer als
Strom aus dem Netz doch wenn die Anlagen
günstiger werden könnte die Speicherung
von Wasserstoff für zu Hause vielleicht
eines Tages so normal sein wie
Solarzellen auf dem Dach
wenn wir es ernst meinen mit der
Energiewende muss Strom aus Wind und
Sonne auch in großem Stil gespeichert
werden technisch wäre das längst möglich
doch Unternehmen und Energieversorger
zögern damit die Energiewende gelingt
müsste die Politik auch bei speichern
die richtigen Rahmenbedingungen setzen
ob wir unsere selbst gesteckten
Klimaziele erreichen entscheidet sich in
den kommenden Jahren auch an den
Stromspeichern